une visite aux airs de campagne
présidentielle après deux premiers jours
dans la cité phocéenne le chef de l'état
a tenu un discours depuis le palais du
pharo pour détailler les contours de son
vaste plan de soutien à la ville de
marseille en tête de ses priorités le
thème de l'insécurité
les chiffres sont bons et il s'améliore
mais il ya une
criminalité de plus en plus violente
qui est largement liée au trafic de
drogue et donc c'était une véritable
traque une politique de harcèlement des
trafics
qu'il nous faut conduire 200 policiers
arriveront en 2022 les deux compagnies
de crs supplémentaire présente depuis
mars seront pérennisés le président de
la république a poursuivi avec la
question du mal logement réitérant
notamment la promesse de réhabiliter dix
mille logements insalubres dans les 15
prochaines années nous nous étions
accordés sur un objectif de
réhabilitation et l'a déjà une fois
encore l'état a pris ses responsabilités
en prenant une politique qui n'est
normalement pas la sienne mais en
assumant cet objectif de réhabilitation
de dix mille logements dans les 15
prochaines années les chantiers doivent
s'engager immédiatement
je compte sur la mobilisation de tous
les acteurs avaient maintenant désigner
un directeur général les choses sont à
construite allons-y et sur ce sujet les
marseillais aimeraient voir emmanuel
macron joindre les actes à la parole
certains ne cachent pas leur scepticisme
et dresse à nouveau un constat alarmant
mars et c'est sale c'est ça on est mal à
loger on est mal on est mal
renvoyé aider des gens qui hésitent à 10
comme quoi renouvelle les toilettes et
les salles de bains mais c'est un
travail bidon c'est mal fait
olé olé rien on irait à la vérité
incroyable c'est un coup de gomme tout
ça c'est du bluff dans deux mois on vend
plus on parler de tout ça moi je pense
que ça sert à rien du tout si bien vu je
file brin bonjour un peu à droite à
gauche et ça c'est que du cinéma moi je
connais compaq là c'est bientôt les
élections tout ça il veut se faire un
nom à marseille devait se faire beau à
marseille c'est du bluff tout ça c'est
que du bluff après je sais pas
photo ep d'appartements et a dit
le président qui a aussi évoqué
l'éducation appelant à donner une plus
grande marge de manoeuvre aux directeurs
d'école faut qu'on ait des directeurs
d'école à qui iront permet d'avoir un
peu plus d'encadrement
faut que ces directeurs d'école et
puissent choisir l'équipe pédagogique
jeudi plein de gros mots pour beaucoup
de gens là on est conscient
mais je dis ce que j'ai entendu parce
que les parents me disent à tel endroit
les profs viennent plus et c'est ça
arrive parce qu'à des gens qui sont
fatigués travailler trop longtemps dans
des quartiers difficiles des
déclarations qui ont suscité l'ire de
plusieurs syndicats d'enseignants qui ne
veulent pas d'école laboratoire alors
que sa visite dans la deuxième plus
grande ville française s'achèvera ce
vendredi emmanuel macron s'est engagé à
revenir en octobre et février prochain
pour suivre l'évolution des différents
dossiers